اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
[موسيقى]
مراسل العربيه يفيد باطلاق اكثر من 100
صاروخ من غزه نحو مستوطنات اسرائيليه
الرياض تستانف عمل بعثتها الدبلوماسيه في
دمشق وتوجه دعوه للاسد لحضور القمه
العربيه
تدشين عده مشاريع في عدن بتمويل من
البرنامج السعودي من بينها مستشفى ومطار
المحافظه
في الرابعه ايضا
هيئه الفضاء السعودي تؤكد جاهزيه رائدى
ريان وعلي لاجراء اربع عشره تجربه بحثيه
وملتقيات التوظيف تثير تساؤلات العاطلين
عن واقع نتائجها واعداد المستفيدين
الفعليه
حياكم الله قال مراسل العربيه في القدس
بان اكثر من 100 صاروخ اطلقت من غزه
باتجاه مستوطنات اسرائيل وكانت الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه قد ذكرت ان صواريخ من غزه
سادفت تل ابيب وعطلت حركه الملاحه بمطار
بن غوريون واطلقت او اطلقت من غزه عشرات
الصواريخ وتم تفعيل القبه الحديديه واصدر
الجيش الاسرائيلي تعليمات للمستوطنين في
غلاف قطاع غزه بالبقاء في الملاجئ وتحدث
التقارير الاسرائيليه عن اعتراض صواريخ
اطلقت من غزه على عسقلن ذكرت القناه
الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه بان رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو سيعقد اجتماعا مع
قاده الجيش لتقييم الوضع الامني
قبل ذلك اعلن المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي ادرعي ان القوات تستهدف معدات
اطلاق صواريخ تابعه لحركه الجهاد في قطاع
غزه واكد الجيش انه وسع غاراته وكتفها في
عده مناطق متفرقه بالقطاع وفق القناه
الثالثه عشره الاسرائيليه فيما اوضحت
مصادر فلسطينيه ان سلسله من الغارات
الاسرائيليه استهدفت اراضي زراعيه في بلده
بمدينه خان يونس جنوب القطاع وافادت
المصادر بمقتل شخص واصابه اثنين من
المزارعين اثر القصف
[موسيقى]
الجنوب
قالت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان حركه حماس
لم تدخل المعركه حتى الان وان حركه الجهاد
هي المسؤوله عن اطلاق الصواريخ وافادت
مراسله العربيه بان عدد الصواريخ التي تم
اطلاقها من قطاع غزه وصل الى نحو 90 ووصل
عدد منها الى تل ابيب حيث تم تفعيل صفارات
الانذار واظهرت مقاطع مصوره هروب السكان
الى الملاجئ كما ادى الهجوم الى تعطل حركه
الملاحه الجويه في مطار بن غوريون وحدوث
اضطرابات في هبوط واقلع الطائرات
هذه صور مباشره امامنا الان من غزه لتصاعد
اعمده الدخان في القطاع كما ذكرنا قبل
قليل
الجيش الاسرائيلي كان قد اعلن بانه استهدف
معدات اطلاق صواريخ تابعه لحركه الجهاد في
قطاع غزه لكن نستوضح ونستبيا ايضا من
الصحفي احمد حرب ينضم الينا من غزه مرحبا
بك معنا احمد لا زالت اعمده الدخان تتصاعد
في القطاع هل هذه المنصات التي تم
استهدافها من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي
ة في المنطقه
الشراليل
نا المكان الذي تم استهدافه من قبل
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه يعني الط
ائرات التي يستهدفتها خلال الساعات
الماضيه وتقول حسب ما يقول الاعلام
الاسرائيلي انها
منصه للفلسطينيه او لحركه
الاسلام كان هناك اطلاق رشقه من التوريق
باتجاه المستوطنات والبلدات الاسرائيليه
من قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه حتى هذه اللحظه
التصعيد قائم الفعل من الفصائل الفلسطينيه
باطلاق الصواريخ حاصل على
وايضا الغارات الاسرائيليه
يعني بين الفنيه والاخرى هناك غاره في
منطقه متفرقه من القطاع وبالتالي نحن امام
فعل ورده فعل امام هذا التصعيد الحاصل منذ
فجر امس
حتى هذه اللحظه
الوصفات لم تنجح في تهدئه الاوضاع واحتواء
الموقف ومنع انزلاق الامور الى ذلك لان
ربما الاتصالات مع الاتصال الفلسطينيه لن
تاتي ثمارها لانها يعني تلقت ضربه من خلال
اغتيال ثلاثه قاده من حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي في ضربه واحده بعمليه مركزه
ومعقده من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي وهذا يعني
يضع القطاع في حاله من التصعيد جراء
المفهوم على العمليه
ماذا كذلك عن الصواريخ ايضا حتى التي
استهدفت اسرائيل استهدفت تل ابيب عطله
الحركه الجويه كذلك في مطار بن غوريون هل
تحدثت اسرائيل عن اي اضرار ماديه او اي
اصابات جراء هذه الرشقات الصاروخيه من قبل
حركه الجهاد
الاسرائيلي في المناطق والبلديه
الاسرائيليه المحاديه
للقطاع وايضا هناك
في بعض المناطق الاسرائيليه هذه الاضرار
لحقت بسبب الصواريخ التي خرجت منها القطاع
وتجاوزت البلدات الاسرائيليه
ووصلت الى الى مناطق على اطراف تل ابيب
حتى هذه اللحظه يعني
الاحتلال الاعلام الاسرائيلي لا
لا اي اصابات او اي اضرار ماديه بالعاده
ولكن يعني هناك بعض القنوات تقوم بنشر هذه
المعلومات الى الاعلام العبريه لكن على
مستوى الاضرار الماديه والاصابات كما ذكرت
هناك خمسه اصابات في الرشقات من الصواريخ
اعلن عنها الاعلام الاسرائيلي حتى هذه
اللحظه
باتجاه السيد ربما يستمر لايام لاننا نحن
نتحدث عن
فجر امس واليوم
اي حديث عن تهدئه الاوضاع او تدخل مصري او
اممي في الامر حتى ولا
هناك
يعني تعمل على احتواء الموقد اخيرا
باختصار احمد ماذا عن المستوطنات في غلاف
قطاع غزه يعني قيل انها اقليت الالاف
خرجوا ايضا من هذه المستوطنات ما هو الوضع
هناك باختصار
باختصار الجيش الاسرائيلي قام باجلاء
الوطنيين على بعد 40 كيلو من المناطق
المحاديه لل
قطاع من اجل يعني ابعادهم عن الصواريخ
التي سوف تطلقها الفصائل الفلسطينيه حركه
الحركه التجاريه 80% من الحركه التجاريه
توقفت في المستوطنات والبلدات الاسرائيليه
المحاذيه للقطاع بسبب اغلاق كافه المرافق
هناك اكثر من 300 الف طالب اسرائيلي
توقفوا عن العمليه التعليميه بسبب تعليمات
الجيش الاسرائيلي باعلان حاله الطوارئ
والدخول الى الملاجئ والتحصينات في
المستوطنات والبلدات الاستراليه المحاديه
للقطاع هناك ربما نستطيع ان نقول شلل
للحياه في المستوطنات والبلدات
الاسرائيليه
الشكر من غزه انضم الينا الصحفي احمد حرب
شكرا جزيلا لك
تواصل رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
نتنياهو مع رؤساء البلديات في المنطقه
الجنوبيه ليخبرهم بامكانيه توسيع العمليه
العسكريه القائمه في قطاع غزه نتنياهو قال
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يستعد لتوسيع العمليه
العسكريه في غزه وتوجيه ضربات عنيفه هناك
اوصت لجنه الامن في الخرطوم البرهان على
اعلان التعبئه العامه وادخال البلاد في
حاله طوارئ وحظر التجول هذا وطلبه اللجنه
بتوصيات رفعتها الى رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان بالعمل الفوري لمعالجه
الكارثه الغذائيه الحاصله في البلاد
مطالبه اياه بالتصدي بحزم لقوه الدعم
السريع واصفه اياها المتمرده
طلبه الحكومه الباكستانيه الجيش بالتدخل
الفوري لحفظ الامن في العاصمه حيث تشهد
الشوارع اعمال شغب واعتداءات على الاماكن
العامه من قبل مؤيدي رئيس الحكومه السابق
عمران خان من جهه اخرى قرر قاضي التحقيق
تمديد احتجاز عمران خان لمده ثمانيه ايام
رفض القاضي هذا الطلب بالافراج
وكاله الانباء السعوديه الان تنقل بان
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز بعث دعوه الى
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد للمشاركه في
القمه العربيه اذا تلقى الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد دعوه من الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود للمشاركه في القمه العربيه
بمدينه جده في التاسع عشر من مايو الجاري
وقالت الرئاسه السوريه في بيانها ان الاسد
اعرب عن شكره لهذه الدعوه مؤكدا للسفير
السعودي بالاردن نايف السديري الذي نقل
الدعوه ان انعقاد القمه العربيه المقبله
في السعوديه سيعزز العمل العربي المشترك
لتحقيق تطلعات الشعوب العربيه
هذا واعلنت الخارجيه السعوديه عن استئناف
عمل بعثتها الدبلوماسيه في سوريا وذلك
حرصا في الاسهام بتطوير العمل العربي
المشترك وتعزيز الامن والاستقرار في
المنطقه وكذلك تنفيذا لقرار الجامعه
العربيه الاخيره بشان عوده سوريا لانشطه
واجتماعات الهيئات والمنظمات التابعه لها
قال وزير خارجيه الروسيه ان السعوديه لعبت
دورا كبيرا بعوده سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه اضاف لابروف ان الجهود الدوليه
مستمره في وضع خارطه طريق لتطبيع العلاقات
السوريه التركيه
ومشاركه سوريا في الجامعه العربيه واود
التاكيد هنا على الدوري الكبير الذي بذلته
السعوديه والجهود البناء في هذا الصدد
وبناء على جهود مشتركه ولقاءات على مستوى
وزراء الدفاع ومندوبي ووزراء الخارجيه
لتركيا وايران وسوريا توصلنا لتفاهمات حول
الوضع في سوريا ونامل ان يسهم اجتماعنا في
وضع خارطه طريق لتطبيع العلاقات السوريه
التركيه وهنا نؤكد مبدا روسيا الاساسي وهو
استعاده سوريا السيطره على كل اراضيها
وضمان عوده اللاجئين الى مناطقهم
اطلقت اليوم مجموعه البنك الاسلامي
للتنميه اجتماعاتها السنويه في جده التي
تستمر لثلاثه ايام وذلك
للبحث بالتحديات التي تواجه البلدان
الاعضاء في البنك الاسلامي للتنميه وستجمع
الاجتماعات السنويه لمجموعه البنك
الاسلامي للتنميه لهذا العام وزراء من 57
دوله اعضاء وكبار المسؤولين الحكوميين
ورؤساء المنظمات الدوليه هذا وتعد
الاجتماعات السنويه للمجموعه بمثابه منصه
مهمه للقاده العالمين وصانعي السياسات
والفاعلين ايضا في مشهد التنميه
اذا نتابع واياكم مشاهدينا الان نعود الى
الصوره من غزه يبدو بان هناك قصف اذا
اسرائيلي على اهداف في قطاع غزه كما نشاهد
تصاعد اعمده الدخان امامنا اذا سلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي كما نشاهد واياكم الان على
شاشه العربيه
يقصف امامنا منصات صواريخ تابعه للفصائل
الفلسطينيه في غزه هذا الاستهداف لم يكن
الاول هذا اليوم رشقات من الصواريخ التي
اطلقت باتجاه
تل ابيب باتجاه ايضا مطار بنكوريون رد
عليها الجيش الاسرائيلي باستهداف منصات
اطلاق هذه الصواريخ
والتصعيد كان قد بدا منذ يومين بعد ان
استهدفت اسرائيل قاده في حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي الفلسطينيه ثلاثه قيادات من حركه
الجهاد
ذلك ايضا نفذت عمليات اعتقال واسعه في
الضفه الغربيه زاد بعد ذلك
التصعيد ايضا بالرد من الفصائل الفلسطينيه
او من حركه الجهاد تحديدا ما دفع ايضا
الجيش الاسرائيلي
ما قال ايضا
بانه استهداف لمعدات اطلاق صواريخ تابعه
لحركه الجهاد في قطاع غزه يبدو كذلك بان
هذه الصور التي نتابعها الان استمرارا
لقصف سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي لمنصه صواريخ
تابعه للفصائل الفلسطينيه كما نتابع
امامنا الان
عود مره اخرى الى جده ينضم الينا من هناك
الدكتور محمد بن سليمان الجاسر رئيس
مجموعه البنك الاسلامي للتنميه الدكتور
محمد مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض هذا
الاجتماع هو ياتي تحت شعار اقامه الشراكات
درعا بالازمات
لماذا دكتور
اولا اهلا وسهلا بكم كما تعلم اخي خلال
السنوات الماضيه عانت الدول الاعضاء
والعالم كله بشكل عام من ازمات متتاليه
سواء بدات في الكورونا ثم حصلت في ارتفاع
اسعار الاغذيه بسبب النزاع في اوروبا ثم
ايضا ارتفاع الفوائد التي
اصبحت يعني عبئا على كثير من الدول
المدينه ولذلك نحن في البنك الاسلامي
وجدنا انه بالرغم من كل ما نقوم به وتقوم
به الدول والمؤسسه الماليه الاخرى اننا
نحتاج الى تظافر جهود بشكل اكبر وهذه هي
الشراكات التي نتكلم عنها لاننا مع بعض
نستطيع ان نعمل ونؤثر بشكل اكبر مما كان
في الماضي ولذلك الشراكات تدرى الازمات
الى حد كبير بالحديث عن الازمات الدكتور
هناك ربما الازمه الاهم والابرز هذه
الايام وهي الازمه السودانيه والسودانيه
من ضمن دول الاعضاء ايضا في البنك
الاسلامي ما مدى تاثير اليوم الازمه
السودانيه على عملكم الذي ستقدمونه ايضا
للسودان في هذه الازمه الراهنه دكتور
ابتداء نبتهل الى الله العلي القدير ان
يرفع عن اخواننا واخواتنا في السودان هذا
هذه الحرب وهذا النزاع وان يعود السلم وان
يعود السودان للعب دوره البناء السودان
عضو مهم جدا لدينا لنا نشاط كبير في
السودان عندنا مشاريع بلغ تمويلها تراكمي
حوالي 1700 مليون دولار
ونتطلع ان شاء الله الى عوده السلم باسرع
وقت ممكن لكي نعبي موارد جديده لمساعده
السودان
للنهوض الاقتصادي كما تعلم اخي السودان
فيها ثروات هائله جدا كنا دائما نقول انها
هي سله غذاء المنطقه كلها ولذلك نحن من في
قراضنا كان حوالي 40% من اقراضنا كله
للقطاع الزراعي في السودان فان شاء الله
نرجو ان الجهود القائمه الان بايقاف هذا
النزيف تنجح
ونعود نحن كرجال تنميه وسيدات تنميه وبنوك
تنمويه نعود للعب دورنا الذي نفضله في
بلاد في البلاد الاعضاء في هذه المؤسسه
العتيده لكن الدكتور هو السؤال يعني بشكل
دقيق عن الوضع عن الازمه الاقتصاديه التي
تمر فيها السودان اليوم يعني جزء من
التنميه هو هو مساعده الاقتصادات
المناره او على الاقل الاقتصادات التي
تعاني من اضطرابات او حروب والسودان هو
نموذج يمكن بارز هذه الايام فبالتالي ما
الذي ستقدمونه في هذا الاطار للسودان في
الوقت الرابع
نحن مؤسسه ماليه متعدده الاطراف تقرض
للحكومات ولذلك نحن ننتظر الاستقرار ان
شاء الله في السودان حيث نقوم بذلك وايضا
نقوم في نفس الوقت
نقوم بتقييم الوضع الامن
للمتطلبات الانسانيه بحيث ان شاء الله ان
نستطيع ان نقوم ببعض من ذلك مثل ما قمنا
به من خلال الزلازل التي اصابت تركيا
وسوريا خلال الفتره الماضيه فنحن ندرس
يوميا الان ونحلل التطورات القائمه في
السودان العزيز اداء مجموعه البنك
الاسلامي للتنميه دكتور يعني تواجه اقتصاد
عالمي متقلب اقتصاد علمي مهدد حتى ايضا
ربما بالركود هذا العام او نهايه هذا
العام 2023 كيف تتعاملون مع هذه
الاحتمالات
طبعا
التحديات كبيره جدا ولكن ولله الحمد
ابشركم ان اداء اقتصادات الدول الاعضاء
لدينا
في المجمل جيده اكثر من خمسه بالمئه خلال
العام الماضي ولكن ايضا نحتاج الى زياده
الاقراض للدول الاعضاء لانها بحاجه
لزياده مصروفاتها التنمويه في بلادها
فمثلا العام الحالي ارتفع
ارتفع مقدار القروض التي قدمها البنك
الاسلامي بحوالي بحوالي
34% هذه نسبه جيده مقارنه بالعام الماضي
يعني حوالي اكثر من مليار دولار زياده عن
العام ايضا
الصرف على المشاريع القائمه ذات خلال هذا
العام ونتطلع ان شاء الله وايضا الدكتور
بالحديث عن المشاريع وش ابرز المشاريع
اللي اليوم لديكم في البنك او المشاريع
اللي انتم تركزون عليها في دعمها
والتنميتها كذلك
لدينا من الناحيه التنمويه خاصه على المدى
البعيد هي البنيه التحتيه الطرق محطات
الكهرباء المياه الزراعه المدارس
المستشفيات ولكن ايضا كما تعلم بسبب
الازمات المتلاحقه عملنا برنامج ايضا
للدعم الغذائي حوالي عشره مليار دولار
للدول الاعضاء ثم ايضا قمنا بمشروع مع
الصناديق الاقراض العربيه عن طريق لجنه
التنسيق العربيه قمنا ايضا بوضع برنامج
لمكافحه
التحديات المناخ حوالي 24 مليار دولار
البنك الاسلامي لوحده التزم بثلاثه عشر
مليار دولار لانه مساله البيئه والمناخ
اصبح تحدي كبير يواجه كثير من دولنا ودول
العالم كلها فلذلك نحن نواكب كل التطورات
التي تحصل في الاقتصاد العالمي والازمات
التي يواجهها وننبري بسرعه بمحاوله
المساعده في التخفيف من اثارها اشكرك جزيل
الشكر جدا انضم الينا الدكتور محمد بن
سليمان الجاسر رئيس مجموعه البنك الاسلامي
للتنميه شكرا يا دكتور
اعلن البرنامج السعودي لتنميه اعمار اليمن
عن افتتاح حزمه مشاريع تنمويه وذلك بدعم
وتمويل في سبع قطاعات حيويه تاتي هذه
المشاريع التنمويه الحيويه ضمن
229 مشروعا ومبادره تنمويه سعوديه اشار
البياني الافتتاح مستشفى عدن العام ومركز
القلب والذي بدوره سيخدم نصف مليون مستفيد
سنويا الا وقد تم تدشين المرحله الثالثه
لمشروع مطار عدن الذي يشمل اعاده تاهيل
المدرج الرئيسي والملاحه
مستمرين في دعم الاشقاء في اليمن في كافه
المجالات في كافه المجالات السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والتنمويه المستشفى عمل سعودي
عملنا مع الحكومه اليمنيه مع السلطه
المحليه في عدن على استكمال بشكل كامل
واعاده تهيله ثم تجهيزه
وعقدنا اتفاق لمده ثلاث سنوات لتشغيل
المستشفى بشكل كامل مطار عدن الدول
انتهينا المرحله الاولى والثانيه سنبدا ان
شاء الله في وضع حجر بعد قليل ان شاء الله
المرحله الثالثه وهناك ايضا الكثير من
المشاريع في عدن قرابه 46 ما بين مشروع
كبير ومتوسط صغير من ضمنها مشروع ايضا
الطريق البحري في عدن بحول الله فخامه
الرئيس دائما يشدد على استعجال تنفيذ هذه
المشاريع
طبعا هذا التجهيز المستشفى تم بجهود كبيره
وهذه الجهود طبعا تكللت بالنجاح اليوم
والتكلفه اجماليه تجاوزت 25 مليون دولار
طبعا هناك الكثير من المشاريع الاخرى التي
سندشنها وسنفتتح اليوم هناك تدشين اليوم
ووضح حجر الاساس لمطار عدن الدولي
وسيكون هذا المطار ربما من اكبر المطارات
في المنطقه
الرابع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
هيئه الفضاء السعوديه تؤكد جاهزيه ترى
ايدي الفضاء رائدي الفضاء ريان وعلي
لاجراء اربع عشره تجربه بحثيه
حياكم الله من جديد محافظة الاحساء
انطلاقه ملتقى توظيف والتدريب 2023
بالكليه التقنيه بالاحساء يستهدف الملتقى
توفير اكثر من
5,300 فرصه وظيفيه لمخرجات المنشات
التدريبيه بالاحسال البنين والبنات في 44
شركه في المنطقه الشرقيه حيث ارتفع عدد
الفرص الوظيفيه المطروحه في الملتقى الى
52% عن النسخه الماضيه
وافق مجلس الوزراء السعودي على انشاء
برنامج سخاء والذي يهدف الى تحقيق حجم
مشروعات بقيمه 20 مليار ريال خلال خمس
سنوات
برنامج سخاء
يهدف لاقامه مشروعات بعشرين مليار ريال
يقدم محفزات للمشاريع التنمويه الناشئه
مده البرنامج خمس سنوات
ثلاث ركائز استراتيجيه تشجيع مساهمه
الباذلين تحقيق الحوكمه والشفافيه وتطوير
فرص تنمويه
مئه فرصه في مجالات التعليم والصحه
والبيئه والسياحه والثقافه والتقنيه
نعود مره اخرى الى موضوع ملتقى التوظيفي
الاحسان من هناك ينضم الينا عميد الكليه
التقنيه في الاحساء عبد الله ذكر الله سيد
عبدالله مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
وخليني اسال في البدايه عن هذا الملتقى كم
شخص تستهدفون توظيفه في هذا الملتقى
المتوقع والفعل كذلك
اهلا وسهلا بكم نرحب بكم في الكليه
التقنيه بالاحساء
طبعا المستهدف الان العدد كبير لكن الحمد
لله استطعنا خلال هذه الفتره البسيطه
توفير 5,300 فرصه وظيفه للبنين والبنات
ونستهدف مخرجات الكليات التقنيه وايضا
المعاهد الصناعيه بالمنطقه
التوظيف مباشره
طبعا في في مراحل تعرف التوظيف الان لا
يتم بصوره السريعه في توظيف مباشر وحددنا
للشركات اركان لاجراء المقبلات الشخصيه
وتوقيع العقود بصفه مباشره طيب
كثير يسال الاستاذ عبدالله عن عن واقع
نتائج مثل هذه
الملتقيات ويعني بانه دائما تنظم هذه
الملتقيات عدد من الشركات او الجهات ايضا
كذلك
والوعود بفرص وظيفيه لكن يعني تكون الفرص
الوظيفيه فيها شحيحه جدا لحد انها لا
تتوازى مع اسم حتى ملتقى
طبعا
حرصنا احنا في في الملتقى اللجنه
الاشرافيه للملتقى توثيق الفرص من الشركات
يعني الشركات لما احنا خاطبنا الشركات
ارسل وطلبوا الفرص الفرص هذه موثقه ولله
الحمد نحن نتابع تابع الفرص الوظيفيه بصفه
مستمره عندنا متابعه شهريه لعدد الفرص
الحقيقيه التي تم توظيفها
النسخه السابقه كم تم توظيف شخص ايضا
استاذ عبد الله وهل انتو تتابعوا بعد ما
يتوظفوا الاشخاص في الشركات عقودهم هل
استمروا خرجوا من هذه الشركات هل مثلا
فتره التجربه استغنوا عنهم
لا طبعا تعرف هذا السوق عرضه طلب انا
اعتقد يعني برايي الشخصي ما في شركه ياتي
لها شخص متميز ويمتلك المهارات انها
تستغني عنه لكن في بعض الشباب يعني يطمح
الى التغيير يجلس في الشركه هذه سنه ثم
ينتقل الى شركه اخرى ثم ينتقل الى الشركه
اخرى هذا يعني هذا هذا اللي نراه في السوق
الان طيب الدكتور
في شركتكم مع هذه الجهات يعني وربما
المؤسسات او الشركات او او غيرها يعني كم
تستهدفون كل عام توظفوا قطاع الاعمال قطاع
الاعمال قطاع الاعمال بشكل كامل لا
احنا في كل في كل سنه هذه النسخه الثانيه
من ملتقى التوظيف التدريب طبعا الملتقى
شقين الشق الاول توفير فرص وظيفيه الشق
الثاني التدريب احنا استهدفنا الان في في
هذا الملتقى تدريب
12,000 متدرب ومتدربه تلقوا التدريب
ولله الحمد خلال الفتره الفتره ما قبل
الملتقى واثناء الملتقى الى الفتره الى
الى يوم امس دربنا قرابه 12,000 متدرب
ومتدربه وحصلوا على بعض المهارات المختلفه
في الذكاء الاصطناعي ومشاريع اخرى وايضا
موضوعات اخرى متنوعه هم لسه الطلاب يا
دكتور ولا خريجين وهذا تدريب منتهي
بالتوظيف او
لا طبعا دائما الملتقيات التوظيف يصاحبها
ورش عمل وبرامج تدريبيه ما قبل الملتقى
واثناء الملتقى للتحضير مثلا كيف تجتاز
المقابله الشخصيه باللغه الانجليزيه ايضا
السوفتس
المهارات الاخرى اللي يحتاجها الخريج
لاجتياز المقابلات هذا كان الهدف من الورش
العمل والبرامج اي نعم البهارات البسيطه
ممتاز طيب الان ايضا لو كان في احد الان
مثلا يشاهدنا استاذ عبد الله وسمع انه في
ملتقى للتوظيف وشخص يبحث عن عن وظيفه انت
شخصيا تنصح يروح
هل بيجد فرصه ولا المساله صعبه طبعا
لكن التوظيف صعب او يكاد يكون يعني محصور
جدا على على فئه قليله
احنا هدفنا في الكليه وفي في المؤسسات او
المنشات التدريبيه التابعه المؤسسه العامه
للتدريب التقني والمهني نساعد ونجد فرص
وظيفيه حقيقيه للخريجين نحن هدفنا يعني
هدفنا بالدرجه الاولى للتدريب ولكن مبادره
معالي محافظ المؤسسه العامه للتدريب
التقني والمهني الدكتور احمد الفهيد فرصه
وظيفيه لكل خريج واحنا فعلا يعني العام
الماضي والسنه هذه وجدت فرص كثيره حتى
تفوق عدد الخريجين لكن تعرف انتشاب موضوع
عامل البعد المكاني وان الوظيفه مثلا تبعد
مسافه بعيده قد تكون عائق في استمرار
استمرار الموظف في نسبه الخريجين اللي
توظفوا يا دكتور اخيرا
طبعا في في احصاءات طبعا في متابعه عندنا
في الكليه وفي كل منشاه تدريبيه يتم
متابعه الخريجين لكن نحرص احنا خلال السته
شهور الاولى من الخريج يكون حصل على فرصه
وظيفيه موضوع المتابعه تعرف الان الاعداد
مهوله انهم يتخرجون فمن صعب بمكان نتابع
كل الخريجين لكن نحن نتابعهم خلال السته
شهور الاولى اشكرك جزيل الشكر بالتوفيق
لكم ان شاء الله من الاحسان ضميريه لعميد
الكليه التقنيه في الاحساء السيد عبد الله
شكرا لك
تبدا العربيه الجمعه المقبله بث الجزء
الثامن من برنامج على خطى العرب والذي
يتتبع القبائل العربيه وابيات شعرهم وقصص
الرحاله والعلماء لتحديد الخريطه الاولى
لحجر اليمامه ثم توسيعها حتى ثم توسعها
عفوا حتى اصبحت الرياض بامتدادها الذي
نعرفه اليوم هذا ويهتم البرنامج الذي
يقدمه الدكتور عيد اليحيى على تراث واثار
الجزيره العربيه وابرز الحضارات التي قامت
عليها عبر التاريخ
ومعي هنا في الاستوديو مقدم برنامج على
خطه العرب الزميل لعيد يحيى حياك الله يا
دكتور رساله فيك معنا في نشره الرابعه اول
شيء الحمد لله على السلامه الله يسلمك وصل
الجزء الثامن ايش الجديد ايش المختلف في
هذا العام ايضا يا دكتور
فقط انه معلومات جديده من الميدان
تركيز على اهم عاصمه في العالم اللي هي
عاصمتنا العظيمه الرياض يعني تاريخها
القديم الظارف القدم الاحداث اللي مرت
عليها من ناحيه جغرافيه من ناحيه انسانيه
ومن ناحيه اثريه
هذا هو الجديد كل الحلقات ستكون في الموسم
الثامن هذا نركز على الرياض على تاريخ
الرياض على تاريخها من من القدم يعني نحكي
عن عن مئات السنين ولا عن الدول السعوديه
الثلاث ولا لا انا يعني الاف السنين الى
الدوله السعوديه الثالثه طبعا من التاسيس
الدوله السعوديه الاولى ثم الثانيه ثم
الثالثه قبلها يعني العصر الاسلامي كله
وقبل الاسلام لكننا بدانا من ما وجدناه من
اثار موجوده في الرياض تعود لعصور قديمه
جدا الى العصور الحديثه
يا دكتور
مفاتيح او عطنا يعني خلينا نقول يعني ابرز
الاشياء اللي حتكون في في البرنامج
واكتشفتوها سواء كانت جديده بالرياض ايضا
في اكتشافاتك ومن خلال هذه الرحله او شيء
يعني ممكن نعلق عليه في البدايات والله هو
المواقع الاثريه لانه حنا في خطى العرب
نمشي على منهجيه ليست قصص احنا لسنا قصصيا
انت منهجيا اي منهج نمشي على منهج اللي هو
علم الاثار علم الانسان
علم الجغرافيا هذه منهجيه ثلاثيه اسمها
ثلاثيه المعرفه الوطنيه وكلها تؤثر ببعضها
لا يمكن الانسان
يعني يتطور ويتحرك من دون تاثير جغرافي
وهذا الجغرافيا يكون فيها اثار فنادور حول
الثلاثه اركان ذي اذا ما في اثر عن الكلام
اللي نتكلم فيه اثر ميداني شاخص لا نتكلم
عنه وبالتالي اللي يشوف على خطه العرب ما
يشوف قصص
يعني انت ما تدعو انه يستمع الى قصص فيها
على الخطوه العرب هذه القصص اسمها
الميثادولوجي لو نبي نتكلم عن قصص اقدر
اجلس على الكرسي في اي مكان يعني في
محاضره وجامعه واتكلم لكن هذه قصص ليس لها
ما يسندها من الدليل الميداني لكن عمل خطى
العرب سواء هذا الموسم الثامن عن الرياض
او المواسم السابقه هو اذا ما في شيء يؤدي
يؤيد الكلام الذي نقوله من الميدان لا
نتكلم عنه اذا في شيء يؤيد نتكلم عنه فهو
بتركيز عن الرياض تاريخه ويهم العالم
العربي
والسعوديين والخليجيين لانه هذه المنطقه
كانت وما زالت لعبت دورا عظيما على مر
الحضارات لمنطقه الرياض هنا ليس دوله
جديده ولا كما يعني يعني سنين الماضيه
يعني يقيل لنا والافلام الخارجيه هذه بلاد
طلعت من الرمل وبدو ما يخالف بدو شيء
لكنها لا هي لعبت دور حضاري قديم جدا ما
زالت الى اليوم كذلك
الدكتور في كثير من جماهير على خط العرب
اتكلم مش من الناس منهم خاصتك يعني جماهير
البرنامج يقول انت يا دكتور تركز على
مناطق معينه بذاتها او يمكن تعيد التكرار
على هالمناطق تتوسع في تاريخها اكثر وفي
مناطق اخرى اغفلتها او ما زرتها الى الان
بصراحه ما عمري كررت من الموسم الاول
والحين دخلنا الموسم الثامن ما كررت موضوع
مره اخرى نتنقل صحيح
تكرار المنطقه مش الموضوع
جغرافيه هذا اول مره نسوي عن الرياض بهذا
التوسع ان شاء الله انا فهمت سؤالك كل مدن
المملكه وقراها سنمر عليها بحول الله
تعالى من اقصى الجنوب الى اقصى الشمال
وبنقص الشرق الى الغرب الى الوسط
حوالي 25 حلقه كامله يعني لكن ان شاء الله
بتكون شامله عن الرياض وتاريخ الرياض
بالتوفيق لكم ان شاء الله يا دكتور شكرا
جزيلا لك على الانضمام اليه في نشره
الرابعه كان معي هنا في الاستديو مقدم
برنامج على خطى العرب الزميل شكرا لك
رابع مستمره وفيها
شركه
الامريكيه تتخذ من الرياض مركزا لتوزيع
منتجاتها في الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت الهيئه السعوديه
للفضاء عن جاهزيه رواد الفضاء لمهمه محطه
الفضاء الدوليه التي من المخطط اطلاقها في
الربع الثاني من العام الحليب اشارت
الهيئه في بيانها ان رايدي الفضاء
السعوديين ريان برناوي وعلي القرني قد
اكمل فتره التجارب محاكاه اختراق الغلاف
الجوي للارض بنجاح مؤكده ان هذه المهمه
تهدف لاجراء اربع عشره تجربه بحثيه علميه
رائده في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى منها ثلاث
تجارب تعليميه توعويه خلال الرحله
الفضائيه والتي تاتي ضمن برنامج المملكه
لرواد الفضاء
اعلنت شركه الامريكيهربو المتخصصه
بالمنتجات الصحيه بانها ستتخذ من السعوديه
مركزا لتوزيع منتجاتها في الشرق الاوسط
وافريقيا جاء هذا بموجب الاتفاقيه التي
وقعتها مع المنظمه او مع المنطقه
اللوجستيه المتكامله في الرياض وشركه
الكوريه
او سي جي لوجستيك الامريكيه وبحسب
الامريكيه انها استثمرت اكثر من 30 مليون
دولار في عمليات جرد البضائع القادمه من
الولايات المتحده في السعوديه
صناعه تعد من الحرف التقليديه التراثيه
التي عرفت بها مدن شرق السعوديه تعتمد في
صناعتها على نبات الاصل وتستخدم في
المنازل والمساجد وايضا في الزينه الا ان
ظهور السجاد الصناعي يهدد بقاء هذه الحرفه
القديمه
[موسيقى]
لا تزالوا هذه الحرفه اليدويه حيه وبقيه
في مدينه القطيف خاصه وفي مدن الساحل
الشرقي في السعوديه عموما صناعه المديد
حرفه تراثيه يعمل بها احمد ابو خليل احد
الحرفيين الذين برعوا فيها مارسها منذ سن
الخامسه عشره حتى الان بديت في الشغله هذه
تعلمتها من عمري 15 سنه
لغايه الحين سبعين سنه تعلمت مع الوالد
وطبعا ختمت الشغل وقمت كله اشتغل وياه ما
في الا انا
في اي مهرجان طلبوا انا انجيل نشارك
وبعدين هات الشغله هذي
زي ما تقول قديمه
الاصل هو الحبال من الادوات التي يحتاجها
الحرفي في صناعه المديد التي تتنوع
منتجاتها كالسجاد المنزلي وفرش المساجد
قديما واستخدامات اخرى في التزيين ادوات
الشغل هذه الاسهل بعدين يتكون من الحبال
هذه صناعه الاصل والاحبال بس طبعا هذا
الاسهل الاول قديما يقبعوا الاسهل نشتري
الحين خلاص ما احد يقصه هذا خلاص هدف راشد
الاول ما في ذل ما في الا هالمده هذه حق
المساجد حق المحلات البيوت وهذه ذكرياته
ما بين دخول المنسوجات غير التقليديه
المعتمده على الالات الحديثه وقله
الحرفيين في صناعه المديد تواجه هذه
المهنه بحسب الحرفيه ابو خليل خطر
الاندثار ما يستوجب الحفاظ عليها ما في
تدريب وفي الناس قالوا لنا لو جبناكم محفل
تدربكم قلنا حاضرين شوفوا لنا محل ومكافاه
واحنا نقول شي من القطيف علي اللغبي
العربيه
شكرا محمد القناص يتقارب طول الليل
والنهار في البلدان العربيه عكس الدول
الاوروبيه التي تكون الغلبه للنهار صيفا
وفي الليل شتاء التفاصيل في تقويم معقد
الزعل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
النجوم موجوده بالليل والنهار لكن قوه
شعاع الشمس تجعلنا لا نشاهدها نهارا فهي
مخفيه خلف شعاعها ولو خرجنا خارج الغلاف
الغازي لشاهدنا النجوم بشكل دائم على شكل
نقاط ليش لانه ما في نهار فالنهار صفه
ملازمه للارض ينتج عن تحوش وعاء الشمس الى
ضوء عن طريق الغلاف الغازي وايه لهم الليل
نسلخ منه النهار فاذا هم مظلمون
[تصفيق]
وكوكب الارض يوجد عليا هليل ونهار اذا
طلعت الشمس صار نهار واذا راحت الشمس صار
ليل والدول العربيه يتقارب فيها طول الليل
مع النهار والدول الاوروبيه الغلبه للنهار
هذا بصيف والغالبه لليل هذا بالشتاء وعلى
القطبين سته شهور نهار وسته شهور ليل
والنجوم لا تشاهدوا الا ليلا وحديد البصر
يقدر يشوف جرميني سماويين في حال النهار
هما كوكب المشتري وكوكب الزهره والعامه
يقولون والله لاوريكم نجوم القايله
ويقصدون بها كوكبي المشتري والزهره
والنجوم تبعد عنا بعدا سحيقا فاقرب نجم
الينا هو نجم الفا قنطوره يبعد عنا اربع
سنوات
ضوئيه وسنها الضوئيه الواحده هي المسافه
التي يقطعها الضوء وهو يسير بمسافه 300
الف كيلو متر
بالثانيه تخيل هذه المسافه والله سبحانه
وتعالى يقول فلا اقسم بمواقع النجوم وانه
لقسم لو تعلمون عظيم
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابعه بابرز عناوينها
مراسل العربيه يفيد باطلاق اكثر من 250
صاروخا من غزه نحو مستوطنات اسرائيليه
الرياض تستانف عمل بعثتها الدبلوماسيه في
دمشق وتوجه دعوه للاسد لحضور القمه
العربيه
تجين عده عده مشاريع في عدن بتمويل من
البرامج السعودي من بينها مستشفى ومطار
المحافظه
هيئه الفضاء السعوديه تؤكد جاهزيه ايدي
الفضائيين وعلي لاجراء اربع شتات تجربه
بحثيه
نهايه الرابعه الى اللقاء
متابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات